tous fassiez aussi peu de calme
messieurs le président chacun
d'aujourd'hui madame la ministre de la
santé
vous avez inauguré avec la maire de
paris la seule salle de shoot de france
rompant rompant oui vous pouvez
applaudir ça change rien rompant un
consensus politique suivie par tous les
gouvernements
c'est une fausse bonne idée ces salles
ne sont pas utiles pire elles sont
dangereuses elles ne sont pas utiles car
notre offre de réduction des risques est
l'une des plus performantes au monde
avec deux tiers des usagers traités dans
des centres spécialisés overdose divisé
par 5,5 fois moins qu'en allemagne pays
pourtant des salles de shoot
contamination par vih divisé par quatre
mais aussi quatre fois moins
d'héroïnomanes qu'en suisse quatre fois
moins de cocaïnomanes qu'en espagne
autre pays des salles de shoot
ces salles sont aussi dangereuses
d'abord parce que tout médecin sait bien
que nul intoxication ne peut être traité
par le produit qu'il a créé d'où leur
condamnation par nos académies de
médecine de pharmacie et parlant des
médecins mais aussi par les riverains
qui redoutent ces zones de non droit et
d'implantation des trafics autour d'une
salle ouverte aux heures de bureau
surtout elle brouille le message de
l'état qui ne peut mener une politique
de désintoxication tout en accompagnant
la consommation banalisant voir
légitimant la drogue par une
dépénalisation de fait alors qu'en la
matière les interdits sont essentiels le
pire c'est que c'est ça ne résoudront
pas non plus les contaminations puisque
les usagers problématiques de drogue
sont hélas déjà porteurs de ces mots tu
médites et sortir les jeunes de la
drogue ce n'est certainement pas les
aider à se droguer soi-disant proprement
pour un résultat improbable
alors madame le ministre dit nous
franchement la prochaine étape c'est la
dépénalisation et la légalisation
la parole est à mme haddad marisol
touraine ministre des affaires sociales
et de la santé
oui merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
philippe goujon oui ce matin g
inaugurée et votre collègue seybah
dagoma étaient présentes
la première salles de consommation à
moindre risque qui ouvre ses portes en
france dans quelques jours j'inaugure
est une deuxième salle à strasbourg et
je souhaite que d'autres
expérimentations puisse être possible
sur notre territoire cela fait trente
ans monsieur le député trente ans que
des expérimentations sont menées à
travers le monde
dix pays déjà sont engagés dans cette
politique
et les résultats sont extrêmement
satisfaisant vous savez monsieur le
député ça n'est pas en niant la réalité
qu'on y apporte des réponses
la volonté qui est la mienne la volonté
du gouvernement car c'est la loi de
modernisation de notre système de santé
qui a permis cette expérimentation c'est
de ne pas exclure de ne pas stigmatiser
et au contraire de permettre
l'accompagnement de tous ces salles de
consommation à moindre risque s'adresse
à des femmes et à des hommes éloigné de
tout éloigné de tout qui ne sont pas
dans les systèmes de santé nous avons
des objectifs de santé publique les
overdoses son diminuer les risques de
contamination sont diminués nous avons
des objectifs sociaux faciliter la
réinsertion et monsieur le député nous
avons des objectifs de sécurité car qui
peut se satisfaire lorsque des enfants
trouvent des seringues souillées dans
les bacs à sable ou dans l'est dans les
cages d'escalier
ce que nous voulons c'est éviter cela
alors monsieur le député ça n'est pas en
stigmatisant
ça n'est pas en dénonçant que l'on
résout les problèmes
la volonté de ce gouvernement c'est
d'accompagner de soigner et de soutenir
ceux qui en